how many games have you googled this  year did you find strategies for The  Witcher 3 s contracts or look up a  trophy guide for the phantom pain  wondering what Google's top trending  game of 2015 is the answer may surprise  you the number one overall trendy game  on Google for 2015 is agario it may look  like geography homework to some of you  but the free-to-play browser game of  dots eating smaller dots was ranked  number one in the United States the top  5 also includes fallout 4 Mortal Kombat  X call of duty black ops 3 and Star Wars  Battlefront that's some serious  competition agario is a multiplayer game  in which you play as a cell gobbling up  smaller cells to increase your own size  until you become the biggest blob on the  board you can play it for free right now  at agaric I oh and you can visit Google  for more trending charts I'm Tony and  for everything else in the world of  video games keep it locked at gamespot  com